world leaders have condemned the growing
evidence of war crimes committed by
russian forces in ukraine authorities
are still trying to identify hundreds of
victims of atrocities in the town of
bucha outside the capital kiev
as russian forces withdraw from the
north of the country locals are coming
out of hiding and taking stock after
nearly a month under russian occupation
dw's nick conley visited the small town
of burkief which was in the middle of
intense fighting between russian and
ukrainian forces from late february he
spoke to residents struggling to make
sense of what happened to them
this is
a small town that's just emerging from a
month under russian occupation a month
in which it was on the front lines
between russian and ukrainian forces
toys or sometimes just the words people
or children
it's as much as many residents of this
ukrainian town could think of a plea to
the russian troops to leave them and
their families alone as they hid in
their homes
people in this village spent 27 days
without water 27 days without bread
followed me and his wife held out for
three weeks until the shelling became
too much to bear and they were finally
able to leave for a neighboring village
when they got back after the ukrainian
military had retaken the town their home
had been ransacked by retreating russian
troops
they've gutted everything carried
everything out
all that's left are the walls and the
sofas
they've taken all the electronics i
don't even know where they put it all
over the month they were here the
russians really changed for the worse
i'm just disgusted at the thought that
they were moving around and eating in my
house
at least they didn't sleep here
they just destroyed things for the sake
of it
but the impact on this community goes
far beyond looted homes
locals tell us they were kidnapped and
detained in cellars for days on end
accused by the russians of helping the
ukrainian military
several residents are still missing
feared killed
a priest arrives from a neighboring
village with supplies for those who've
lost almost everything
but it's not food or money that the
locals are asking for
the people here need tranquilizers
many of them have lost everything that
they spent a lifetime saving for
their houses their cars it's all gone
shows us the damp cellar where she her
husband and her neighbours spent some of
the coldest nights of the year
we weren't just hearing the shelling we
could feel it
everything was shaking
all we could do was pray that it
wouldn't hit us we just kept praying
supplies like these kept lubovo and her
husband going during the weeks under
occupation while the shop stayed shut
and leaving home would have meant
running a gauntlet
by the time you've been up and down
these steps a few times you'll lose the
will to do anything else
duboff tells us she and everyone she
knows is exhausted
always waiting for something they can't
quite define unable to ever let go
we didn't used to understand what it was
that people in donbass have been going
through all these years stuck in their
cellars the last month has taught us
what war is
for now the russian army has been pushed
back more than 100 kilometers
but the fear they might return as
suddenly as they appeared is never far
away
our correspondent nick connolly filed
that report joins us now from the
ukrainian capital kia nick you've now
been to several towns surrounding kiev
in the wake of the russian withdrawal
there you've interviewed numerous
eyewitnesses what have you pieced
together about how russian forces are
fighting this war
i think the overarching impression is
one of chaos so in that town where we
just were that we've seen the report of
locals told us that
basically you had forces from all kinds
of different regiments who were
basically on the retreat had sustained
large losses in their first days in
ukraine and basically didn't know each
other so they had
russian soldiers that had no experience
of interacting now suddenly grouped
together again having been surprised by
that ukrainian resistance unable to make
decisions unable to really work out who
was in charge often under-supplied in
terms of food having to either ask the
locals for food or just to take it
breaking into shops that seems to be a
picture we're seeing across the country
and not only shops but also into private
homes we've seen images now from belarus
which is the kind of supply hub for lots
of these russian forces that were in
northern ukraine of russian soldiers in
uniform going to post offices in belarus
sending home huge packages
of pretty obviously looted stuff from
ukraine of car batteries electronics
even washing machines
that really seems to be a pretty
widespread picture and no sense that
there's a lot of
punishment from the kind of superiors
the highs up in the russian army if
their subordinates do that we did hear
from locals though that
it was a mixed picture they had had some
positive interactions some russian
soldiers who had admitted to them that
they didn't want to be in ukraine that
they had believed their superiors who
told them that they were just going on
exercise to the ukrainian border and
that some had even apologized to them
for the behavior of their uh fellow
soldiers um in boots of the place of
those mass killings that we've seen in
recent days one local told us that he
had the impression that they were just
scared they had not really
counted on meeting so much resistance
from the ukrainian army and they
basically saw any civilian out on the
streets trying to get some food as a
potential threat as someone who might
attack them and so he said that the
locals there they really felt every time
they left their homes that they were
being watched through the sights of a
russian gun that every time they left
their houses they were likely to be shot
and it seems like most of the people who
lost their lives in boots were indeed
shot randomly on the streets by soldiers
often on tanks or other armored vehicles
um just taking pot shots at people with
seemingly very little fear of any kind
of accountability
nick russian forces have now pulled back
from those areas around kiev and are
increasing pressure on the donbass
region in the east the ukrainian
government is urging civilians to leave
the east of the country are people
heeding that call
well there definitely are lots of trains
heading west still especially taking
people who've got out of maripool by by
road who then get to cities like
zaporija in the southeast and then make
their journey west from there by train
but it doesn't seem like it is a mass
exodus for now and if the experience the
last few months they need to go by
people on the whole tend to heed those
kind of warnings only when it's too late
only when they can hear the fighting the
shelling close to them um just in the
weeks and months going into this war and
there were all those warnings coming out
of washington out of western capitals
from western intelligence authorities
and time and time again we went to
places that were very vulnerable that
were on the border with russia with very
little in the way of fortifications and
you'd ask people are you worried what is
your contingency plan and people would
say this is all bluff this is just a
political game by the kremlin to put
pressure on ukraine a full-scale war is
unimaginable the russians wouldn't take
those risks and as such people just
discounted it and would tell you they
were actually more concerned about their
job or the fact that their local shop
was going to close down so i think
unfortunately lots of people even though
we're now in second month of war aren't
really able to imagine the war arriving
on their doorstep until it's too late
nick thank you very much our
correspondent nick connolly there in
kiev
and the mayor of mariupol says more than
5 000 civilians have been killed there
as russia continues to lay siege to the
port city
this is what's left of mariupol
most of the residential buildings have
been destroyed
russian bombing and shelling has been
relentless forcing some residents to
live in basements for weeks
still many are reluctant to leave
my husband says we will not leave
mariupol we will stay until the end
whatever happens
he likes living here he's a fisherman he
will not abandon mariupol
those who want to leave face a dangerous
flight the fragile ceasefire means those
trying to reach civilians in the
besieged city are also at risk
our team
tried days and nights
for five days to reach mario ball under
extremely difficult security conditions
we had to pass checkpoints we it was day
and night operation
and relentlessly we tried to reach out
but unfortunately we'd not managed to
reach mario paul because of the city
security
conditions
but the team did manage to drive
civilians to safety more than 200
kilometers away
we decided to go with our child
our family let us go with tears in their
eyes
this is a long and dangerous
[Music]
the journey of mariupol is over for
these families but other civilians are
still trapped there
today is world health day and the world
health organization says there have
never been so many attacks on hospitals
across the globe this year alone has
seen more than 130 health facilities
targeted the majority of them by russian
forces in ukraine
the moment a bomb exploded in the city
of mariopol
and this is what was hit
the maternity and children's hospital
since the start of russia's invasion
more than 90 health facilities
including hospitals like this one in the
city of itsyam have been attacked
according to the world health
organization
some more than once
at the start of the war the main
hospital in the town of volnovoka was
hit
days later it was attacked again
and then again
while dozens of civilians were hiding
inside
trying to escape the shelling
among them was andrey kianyinoff
head of the hospital's trauma center
who was there with his wife and children
the experience still haunts him
lasted about 20 to 25 minutes
my children and i didn't make it to the
basement
we spent all this time in the corridor
of the hospital
we experienced all the shelling first
hand
pavlov
is ukraine's former deputy health
minister
he now runs an organization that's
trying to document each and every
hospital attack
our
main and primary goal is to help
our country and help international
community to hold accountable those
people
who would do those war crimes
and this is what really makes our team
really really motivated
because they feel that they're doing
something very important for this war
but as the war continues
so too to the attacks
hopes of prosecutions
seem a long way off
let's bring in abril benoit here she's
an emergency communications coordinator
with doctors without borders and she
joins me from la vie in western ukraine
thanks for being with us abril your
organization has documented attacks on
numerous hospitals and health facilities
in ukraine is there a pattern are
hospitals being deliberately targeted
would you say
it's very hard to know
the experience that our team had on
monday afternoon at about 3 30 local
time uh in a residential area of
mikolayev that had a high concentration
of hospitals serving civilians
is that it was a a cluster bomb they
were there uh meeting some uh
health authorities in the oncology
hospital just walking in when it uh it
started as a barrage that continued for
roughly 10 minutes and so are the
hospitals targeted or what would be the
reason to to be bombing
a residential neighborhood that had a
high concentration of hospitals we we
would have to leave to others to verify
uh that
per se i know that the world health
organization has been doing this
horrific tally of the number of health
facilities that have been targeted
including ambulances by the way and so
for us it's just always the same uh
concern and outrage that we express that
medical facilities in times of war
should be protected they should be a
place of sanctuary where people can go
and feel safe and that the health
workers the caretakers and the patients
of course can feel like this is going to
be a protected space amid everything
else that's going on
now doctors without borders uh provides
emergency medical aid what's the
situation for your colleagues trying to
provide that aid in ukraine
it's an extremely challenging
environment because there are many areas
that do need humanitarian assistance or
the people would like to have the
opportunity to flee and it's just not
possible so in circled areas of mariopol
certainly but there are others
one of the challenges is that even for
aid providers uh whether it be the u.n
the international committee of the red
cross or independent ngos like doctors
without borders or mit says
is that uh some of the roads are mined
so even if you think okay we're going to
try and reach this area uh
it could be extremely perilous to bring
the cargo in the medical supplies in
that the hospitals inside those zones
are are crying for for assistance for
for some support the other issue is just
uh obstructions there are checkpoints uh
there are officials saying no you can't
go here it's not safe and so there are a
number of obstacles uh to to actually
being able to be effectively in the
places where people need us most
talking about getting into those
difficult areas do you have does your
organization have access abril to those
contested regions in the east of ukraine
donetsk and luhansk
we do not and that's one of the
challenging things we keep trying uh to
be able to offer assistance based on
independent assessments and an ability
to deliver it directly ourselves but
what we are doing right now and there's
a tremendous amount of pressure since
the ukrainian government advised people
yesterday to evacuate immediately a
number of those areas donetsk luhansk uh
even kharkiv is that we are receiving a
lot of calls for our medical referral
train to come and pick up patients from
hospitals that are overburdened in the
east and take those patients transport
them or transfer them to hospitals that
are better able to provide them a safe
place to be able to be treated and
recover
so that train activity the medical
referral train is is now under a lot of
pressure with many many requests and far
too many for us to be able to safely
transport which is why we're developing
a larger train that's kitted up with
more equipment more like an intensive
care unit to be able to to assist
greater numbers of people and make such
a difference for the working flow of
of the hospital uh workload in the east
abril thank you very much for speaking
with us that was abriel benoit from
doctors without borders speaking to us
from libya in western ukraine
ministers are meeting in brussels today
to consider the western alliance's
response to the war in ukraine amid
worries that the conflict could drag on
for months if not years ukrainian
foreign minister dimitra koleba is
attending that meeting just a short
while ago he and nato chief jens
stoltenberg addressed reporters
it is an urgent need to further support
ukraine
and at our meeting later on with the
nato uh foreign ministers i'm certain
that we will address the need for
more air defense systems anti-tank
weapons lighter but also heavier
weapons and many different types of
support to ukraine my agenda is very
simple it has only three items on it
it's weapons
weapons and weapons
we are confident that the best way
to help ukraine now is to provide it
with all necessary
to contain
putin
and to defeat russian army in ukraine
our correspondent jack parrik is
covering that nato meeting in brussels
jack ukraine wants weapons jen
stoltenberg the nato chief says he
expects nato will deliver so are the two
sides on the same page
well
kind of to be honest terry it looks like
dimitro collabor is going to do a pretty
impassioned plea to the nato foreign
ministers through these meetings he said
some really interesting things in this
press conference he
pointed the finger
directly at berlin for not providing as
many weapons as they wanted he said
berlin has time kiev doesn't saying that
the bureaucracy in berlin to get weapons
over the line and to be sending them to
ukraine uh is taking too long he said
that the the decision by germany to
export weapons was a revolutionary step
that called on germany specifically to
do more he also talked about the
difference between defensive and
offensive weapons because that's some of
the discussion around some of the nato
member states and also specifically in
germany and culebra had to say that all
weapons right now are defensive because
they have been invaded um by russia and
there's no longer an offensive weapon
for them they see offensive weapons
simply as weapons that they
need to use to to push that invasion out
he also talked specifically about the
sort of some of the thinking around this
because nato members are slightly
concerned about sending uh weapons to
ukraine
for fear of being dragged into the war
in a more broader sense but what labour
had to say is give there's a simple deal
from the ukrainian side
give us weapons he said we sacrifice our
lives and we prevent the fallout from
this war going out into other european
countries so it was a pretty specific
set of demands he is here in brussels to
try and get weapons from the nato allies
nato's secretary general says we should
be prepared for the long haul in ukraine
is that not an admission jack that
nato's hands are effectively tied in
this conflict
well it's an interesting one isn't it
terry i mean there's there's this
preparation now i think and jen
stoltenberg has been talking over the
last few weeks about this this idea of
the new normal the troops that they've
stationed in eastern nato member states
that they're saying uh you know need to
um
you know are probably likely going to be
a more permanent position now if this
war continues on and rumbles on the
question is how does the nato thinking
shift on this and i think actually what
annalina bairbach the german foreign
minister uh said in response to what
kulaiba was saying regarding german arms
she was talking about the sort of
feelings that europe has and and the
sort of sense of of of what's going on
and what they need to try and do and and
i think there are some shifts and some
discussions happening within the german
government although she was relatively
vague in her response to what ku labo
was saying with the demands for weapons
jack there's mounting evidence of war
crimes being committed by russian forces
in ukraine is this creating a greater
sense of urgency among nato and eu
leaders there in brussels
i think definitely what we've seen over
the last seven days or so there's been
some pretty pretty big statements coming
out of eu leaders we also know that the
ambassadors of the european union are
sitting back down today to try and
see if they can agree on this fifth
round of eu sanctions including an
all-out ban on imports of russian coal
we'll have to wait and see how that goes
there are it seems there is some
stalling as well but i think there is
some impotence impetus after those
atrocities that we saw in butcher
jack thank you very much our
correspondent jack parrik there in
brussels